[Musique]
on essaie voix seul pays au monde un
seul pays au monde où les dieux ou alors
des dieux chantent et dansent pour des
personnes ordinaires comme vous et moi
vous connaissez un pays comme ça
et bien ce pays existe et il est unique
pièce unique dans le monde
il s'appelle le bel un pays merveilleux
où coule la tolérance et la générosité
comme le miel
quand on évoque le mot vaudou tout le
monde est pris de frayeur on pense à la
sorcellerie à la magie à l'envoûtement
vous dites je suis béninois est
immédiatement tout le monde a peur de
vous et pourtant c'est une grande
injustice faite à ce peuple qui a le
mieux
le vaudou n'a rien à voir mais alors là
rien à voir avec la sorcellerie les
envoûtements et la machine mais c'est
quoi alors le vaudou les professeurs de
la faculté des lettres
kim abrite à l'université
d'abomey-calavi ont fait des recherches
sur le phénomène est la conclusion vous
voulez que je vous partage cette
conclusion je partage avec vous le
vaudois n'est rien d'autre qu'une forme
de spiritualité que nous avons hérité de
nos ancêtres et qui leur est fait
venus de l'egypte ancienne c'est aussi
simple que ça alors le vaudou c'est donc
une création sur la base des quatre
éléments l'air l'eau le feu et la terre
tout simplement voilà ce qu'elle est le
vaudou est rien pour maintenir les
hommes dans la discipline et donc pour
protéger la vie et non pas pour donner
la mort vous savez il ya des expériences
merveilleuse qui ont été faites au bénin
lorsque vous avez un village dans ce
pays
ce village est tenu d'avoir une forêt
sacrée il a fallu deux cents ans et la
naissance des sciences de
l'environnement pour dire que ces aires
protégées participe à la sauvegarde de
l'écosystème et de l'environnement nous
parents le savez 2000 ans avant nous
tout simplement avec la culture vaudou
il ya des étangs qui sont interdites à
la pêche pendant des périodes de l'année
parce que disait ton si vous allez il y
à un vaudou dedans qui va vous tuer tout
de suite
et du coup tous les peureux reste à
l'écart de cet étang là mais savez vous
pourquoi on se rend compte après que
c'est là où les a levés vont se cacher
et que les poissons utilisait cet
endroit pour se multiplier et qu'il
fallait donc protéger cet endroit pour
permettre des pêches meilleur par la
suite
est ce que le body n'a pas protégé la
vie je crois que le bodo dans ces
conditions à protéger la vie on peut
multiplier les exemples
alors à partir de ce moment le vos dons
à se créer une culture qu'on appelle
culture vaudou et qui est la culture
dominante au belize je donne un exemple
tous les repas que vous appréciez
tellement je veux parler de abobo
vous voyez abobo ça vous a fait rire et
même le yom lis tous ces plats ont été
destinés d'abord au voodoo avant que les
vodoun les prêtent aux hommes que nous
sommes le i'm your c'est la pâte
destinée aux baudoux vous le savez mais
lorsque vous prenez tous les mets
destiné au vaudou vous comprenez que
c'est mais sont riches en protéines
protéines végétales pour le abobo le
sang qui tire compagnie protéines
animales pour le amis à et le négocier
je ne sais pas s'il y a des gens qui
sont de parents prononcé comme moi dans
la salle mais vous comprenez très bien
ce que je dis voilà pour le se nourrir
maintenant pour le se vêtir vous voyez
j'ai les rois lourd lois sont dans leurs
grands pas et tout c'est méthode cerveau
du vestimentaire sont empruntés aux
photos vous allez maintenant pour le se
loger je suis sûr que vous vous a été
donné de rire d'un béninois qui a acheté
une parcelle et qui a commencé d'abord
par m une clôture et même un portail
avant de commencer à construire la
maison à l'intérieur donc les matériaux
on les passe par dessus le mur
vous n'avez pas observé cela alors
pourquoi cela c'est parce que la culture
vaudou 10 est prescrit que l'espace
qu'on s'approprie comme demeure doit
être sécurisée par une clôture et la
clôture doit être entouré
de plantes médicinales qui constitue la
boîte à pharmacie de la famille modèle
copié sur les couvents et qui au nom la
pharmacopée
voilà pour le seul objet déjà mais vous
avez une architecture vodo vous allez
dans nos grandes villes où ils d'abonnés
et compagnie vous avez une esplanade
dehors qui accèdent aux portails aux
portiques et celle là où ils se font les
manifestations poteau c'est une marque
de fabrique c'est la culture vaudou
maintenant le se soigner toute la
pharmacopée et la phytothérapie ses
expérimentés d'abord dans les couvents
vaudou avant d'être généralisé et
maintenant le top le s'instruire alors
là c'est un professeur d'université
même à la retraite qui vous parle nous
avons beaucoup beaucoup à apprendre de
la théorie de l'éducation des sciences
de l'éducation qui nous vient du vaudou
le vaudou éduque à la conscience et
estime que la science vient pas sur quoi
alors que l'école que nous avons dans
nos avons hérité et qui nous vient de la
colonisation nous éduque à la science
est finalement sans conscience et
finalement vous comprenez que c'est une
de l'âme
ce n'est donc pas un hasard si
science sans conscience n'est que ruine
de l'âme
nous comprenons alors tout le malheur
qui nous arrive aujourd'hui pour éduquer
à la conscience le vaudois utilisent
l'esthétique là parce que c'est que
l'émotion est plus importante que la
raison alors tout ce qui est important
on met ça dans des chansons dans la
musique et on l'accompagné la musique de
danse obligatoire pour que en même temps
que l'esthétique apprécié par l'esprit
le corps se met en mouvement en accord
avec la mélodie
résultat ces lettres tout entier qui est
ouvert est perméable à la pénétration de
la conscience et voilà c'est cela le
vaudou alors qu'est ce que je veux vous
dit
les jeunes étudiants qui sont dans la
salle on nous a appris à avoir peur du
veau dont je dirais comme le un certain
pape n'ayez pas peur
le vaudou ne fait du mal à aucun de ses
enfants
donc n'ayez pas peur
et lorsque vous séparer le cultuel qui
relève des pratiquants du vaudou et qui
sont des retraits jaloux de leurs
prérogatives
il s'appelle pour cela des initiés pour
le laisser leur cultuel et que vous
prenez le culturel
ce qu'ils ont apporté de positif à notre
culture
si vous vous préoccupez de cela alors
cela devient un
gisement d'or inexploitées et vous avez
alors un an une richesse incommensurable
et là aujourd'hui
vous verrez les hommes de théâtre les
hommes des arts de scène l'est les
gracques comment les les plasticiens
baignoire s'inspirant de vos dons font
déjà le tour du monde
alors vos autres aujourd'hui aussi
prenez appropriez vous ce patrimoine
culturel et fait le tour et vous ferez
la différence dans le monde pour la
gloire de notre pays je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]